secretary of state you know there is
this missing case but not
who or where or whether they
self-isolated
how is it that after two months of a
tough lockdown and just one week before
it starts to lift
such a concerning new variant has been
allowed to slip through the net
and professor van tam level with the
british public is there any prospect of
a foreign holiday this summer when new
variants are crossing our borders
and there's still no vaccine with
in-built universal protection
against the evolving virus thanks thomas
well
i i see it the other way around it's
because of the extraordinary
capability of nhs test and trace that
we've been able to identify
these cases and in particular there is a
high chance that the identification of
the sixth
case came through the surge testing that
we put in
around communities where we were
previously looking for
for other variants of concern and we
don't know that for sure
but without the huge surveillance
that we have in terms of the testing
capability
and then the ability to sequence that we
wouldn't know about this
and by sequencing now around 30 percent
of cases that means that we do have a
very good
survey to be able to spot uh variants of
concern like this but as you say
it is critical that people continue to
follow
the rules because that limits the spread
of new variants in the same way that it
limits the spread
of the existing uh variant that is the
the what infects most people
in the country thankfully with
decreasing rates
susan i would just like to add that
sometimes it's it's really important
that
people may have got the test and then
not realized how to complete it or may
have lost their
their form to complete it 119 is
standing by in england
and also the scottish number is
available on the website so we are
imploring people to come forward if they
haven't got their test results
and we will help you find and reconnect
you with that test results
and therefore be able to stop any
transmission
thanks very much